[Music]
this is about Mills Lane
Hills Lane is not the name of this
Street in Reno Nevada Bill's Lane is the
man running in the street come on by
at age 51 Lane is the district attorney
of Washoe County
he's a former amateur boxer who does a
few miles of road work every day rain or
shine
and likes to keep himself in shape
because he still likes to think of
himself as a fighter
a crime fighter of course I hope I never
have to use it but I'm never going to
run from any son of a [ __ ]
if I can't whip him it is too big for me
if there's more than one of them I said
you want to get me brother you better
make your first shot your best because
there ain't gonna be any more
as D.A on a given day those figures he
can lick any defense attorney in the
house I think if you're in that case for
five hours I've heard
for a queen but he
[Music]
what's the name of the game
Lynn has prosecuted 22 murder cases in
his day and hasn't lost to one of them
but winning isn't everything to Mills
Lane sometimes in briefing a prosecution
witness in a murder trial he could be
downright judicial
so do whatever you think is right and do
whatever you think is true
no prosecutor should ever ask anybody
to ever say anything except what the
truth is of course the prosecutor is a
contestant courtroom not a judge or a
referee but though he may never down the
Robes of a judge lame does Don the bow
tie of the referee the dumbest piece of
the power we wear he has been the third
man in the ring at some 40 championship
fights and many boxing people will tell
you Nobody Does it Better
[Applause]
three four five unequivocally those
might as the best referee in the world
and I think he's the best referee that
ever has been
fans don't go to a fight to see the
referee so you've got to keep moving
that's what Lane does if you're watching
the fighters you don't even see the man
he's almost invisible in the way it
works you have to get the respect of the
boxers even when they're a lot bigger
than you are maintenance
you have to know when to let the
combatants have at it side stop trying
to get cold Starling knocks out
Huntington's mouthpiece and when to stop
a fight as he did last month's hunting
installing Championship middleweight Bob
Lane has seen enough
preparation is the key Lane says in the
boxing ring as in the courtroom but
either place he takes his job seriously
asks no quarter and gives none and folks
know when he's down man I hope I know I
came to them and some folks think I'm a
no good son of a [ __ ] and you're
probably right
nobody Fools With Mills Lane my mother
Russia Soul she said told me said Mills
you prosecuted me and I said no man but
I wouldn't have missed the case I got
somebody else to do it nobody
[Music]
thank you